What can I do for my daughter who has obvious hormonal issues?
Well, I don't know what obvious hormonal issues are, whether it has to do with
frequent or infrequent or abnormal periods, abnormal bleeding at periods, or you're talking about
emotional hormonal issues. All those can be signs of hormonal dysfunction. As a per, I don't know
how old your daughter is, whether they're in their teens and they're just starting to get their
period and they're just starting to deal with these different hormonal influxes. If that's the case
diet plays a big role in these hormonal influxes because as we're, if you're eating a typical
American diet, you're exposed to so many bad estrogens and estrogen disrupting
poisons and toxins in a typical American diet that it throws off your hormone balance.
When their newly functioning ovaries are just starting to work and their
pituitary is just starting to kick out the different hormones and stimulates estrogen and
progesterone production and balance. Getting that balance is really important. Certainly you
could do a Dutch test, which is a dried urine hormone test to see where that person is at
and see where the imbalance is to know how to deal with it. Many times a person, a young lady who
has got PMS issues and severe issues with their period, has a deficiency in progesterone and
abundance of estrogen and balancing it out. You know you could take exogenous
topical progesterone that can be very helpful, but I always think it's good to look at the
hormones through a Dutch test. There's different nutrients that can help balance hormones as well.
So if you're talking about hormonal issues that are more emotionally based and they're having
severe mood swings and things, yes, that is tied to estrogen and progesterone, but it also can
be tied to the adrenal and the thyroid gland. So getting their thyroid's tested, getting the
adrenal's tested, which would be done through a Dutch test as well, but getting their thyroid
tested through a blood test, a complete thyroid profile would be very important too because that
can definitely affect moods and issues there. Again, foods and diet is so important because it feeds
back to the whole system. Foods as far as the different foods that would be inflammatory, especially
gluten is going to affect the thyroid directly because gluten is a molecular mimic to the thyroid
gland and sugars are going to affect the adrenal glands. So looking at it, you've got to dig it and
depends on how young this child is and how willing they are to manage their condition and make
dietary changes, whatever you're dealing with, a young person, that is a difficulty to in some
cases, whether they're willing to make, you know, it's hard for anybody to make dietary changes
and certainly somebody in their teens that has got a lot of peer pressure quite over to their
friends house and such. So yes, if you want to make do a case review, we could discuss this and
decide on next best steps.